foreign
[Music]
ERS are electricity meters that don't
have to be read by a person instead they
wirelessly send your home's electricity
use to your utility in real time
your bill then shows how much
electricity you used and when making it
easier to better control your energy use
old technology meters require a human
being to take a meter reading once each
billing period Smart Meters can report
consumption in real time by Wireless
transmission inside the smart meter are
three different electronic circuit
boards the brains of the unit they're
built on large blank fiberglass panels
one panel yields six or eight identical
circuit boards depending on the meter
model in the first machine for tracking
purposes a laser etches a serial number
for each future circuit board the next
machine applies a stencil in the pattern
of the components to be mounted on the
board then spread solder in paste form
across it
the board now wears solder paste shaped
and positioned exactly to receive the
upcoming components
Sheen's two lasers verify that the
solder paste application is perfect
depending on the size of a specific
circuit board component there can be
anywhere from five to twenty thousand of
them stored on a tape reel under a
transparent protective strip
workers Mount the reel for each
component on what's known as a pick and
place machine
this computer-controlled high-speed
device peels back to protective strip
and picks the required parts off each
reel
then places them in their designated
solder pasted position on the board
bulkier components are stored on a
different size rehome which workers
mount on another type of pick and place
machine
it does the same operation as the
previous one only slower due to the
larger size components
the boards now travel through a
soldering oven the Precision controlled
temperature peaking at 468 degrees
Fahrenheit melts then cools the solder
paste fusing all the components to the
board
foreign
next each board undergoes testing
this machine applies electricity to
ensure each and every component meets
specifications
when the board gets the all clear it
moves to the next machine which cuts it
into separate circuit boards
meanwhile robots assemble the meter's
digital display they take a plastic half
circle housing and install liquid
crystal display into its rectangular
window at the next station a robot uses
a vision system to align snaps to attach
a circuit board to the liquid crystal
display
assembling the meter body begins with
the plastic base plate the first station
prints a serial number on the bottom
the next station then flips the base
plate upright and installs the
components of the remote disconnect
switch
this switch enables the electric company
to switch power on and off from any
location
which cover closes up the base the
protruding wire will connect to a
circuit board
station installs two terminals through
the switch cover these function as part
of the switch operation as well as part
of the meter's measurement of
electricity consumed once those
terminals are in an automatic
screwdriver secures the switch cover now
the first of three circuit boards this
one the Metrology board measures energy
consumption
the unit comes off the automated line
and a worker completes the assembly he
attaches a connector to the digital
display circuit board installs the
display then connects the switch wire to
the displays board
the Metrology board sends its
measurements to the display circuit
board which interprets the data and
sends it to a third circuit board which
transmits it by radio frequency to the
utility
once workers have fully assembled the
housing they install a metal tamper
evidence seal
every meter undergoes rigorous final
testing an automated station verifies
the display using a vision system it
checks that the remote disconnect switch
operates properly
that the meter measures electricity
accurately and successfully transmits
and receives messages